Today, I'm going to give you my top
three argument responses that will keep
somebody from getting defensive. It's my
favorite advice that I use every single
day when I walk into the office. If they
work for me, I promise they're going to
work for you, too. When things start to
get heated in a discussion and you can
tell things aren't going well and
temperatures are on the rise, here are
three responses that you can use right
away to help turn a potential argument
back down to a conversation. Number one,
you tell them what you agree with. You
tell them what you agree with. Now, hear
me out. That does not mean you need to
agree with a single word of what they
said. Instead of focus on the content of
the message, instead focus on the
subject matter. For example, I agree
that this topic is worth discussing. I
agree that we need to have this
conversation. When they hear the phrase,
I agree, it automatically breaks down
their wall. Number two, you tell them
what you've learned. You tell them what
you've learned. For example, after
listening, I've learned that this topic
is important to you. When you say, "I've
learned," it makes them feel like
they've educated. It makes them feel
like they're teaching, and it makes them
feel like you're growing in the
conversation and makes them less
defensive. Number three, you tell them
what's been helpful. You tell them that
they've been helpful. For example,
that's helpful to know. It's as easy as
that. Thank you for telling me that's
helpful to know. Whenever they hear that
phrase help or helpful, it makes them
feel like they've invested in their own
mutual understanding and it makes them
less defensive. Now, as you can imagine,
I use these phrases all the time because
in my profession as an attorney, I deal
with conflict every day. I get hired to
handle somebody else's conflict. And the
crazy part is somebody else hires an
attorney of their own to have conflict
with me. And so there are multiple ways
where I have to use phrases that dampen
conversations that stop things from
getting too hot and heated. And these
phrases, why I like them so much is that
they help smooth things over. When I can
tell someone that I agree with something
about what they said, even the topic
itself, even though it's surface level,
even though it's macro level, just
saying that to them calms it down. or
what they've been helpful or I've
learned something or I'm thankful for
something. It helps keep the fire down.
And too often uh in my line of work,
people want to push and push and push
and feel like they can win an argument.
Instead, rather than letting them get
defensive, I smooth it down. Because you
and I both know once somebody gets
defensive in an argument, it's over.
Game over. You're going to have time has
to pass before you can reach somebody.
When somebody gets defensive, that
communication is on lockdown for a while
until it calms down. Uh so the idea with
these phrases is that you never have to
have that pause where they get defensive
and you have to wait and start over
again. Instead, it always keeps the
levels low. Soon as somebody gets
defensive, the communication shuts down.
These phrases help that not happen. So,
let's go deeper on response number one.
When you tell somebody what you agree
with.
Big emphasis here. That does not mean
that you need to agree with the content
of their message. This is not about
who's right and who's wrong. Your your
focus is in the wrong place if that's
where your mind is going. as um as a way
to think about this. Instead of arguing
over where the chair should be located
around the kitchen table and where you
should uh position the couch and
rearrange the furniture, that's too
detailed. Go bigger. Where are you going
to live? What city do you live in? What
street are you on? You're going big
macro into this communication, not into
the nitty-gritty details. So instead of
focusing on I don't agree with what you
said, forget that. Go to the subject. Do
you agree that this subject is worth
talking about? If you do, you find
something about it that you can agree
on. For example, I agree that this is
something we should talk about. I agree
that this is a conversation worth
having. That is incredibly powerful
stuff. Somebody is trying to talk to you
and you can feel that they're getting
defensive and you just calmly say, "I
agree that this is something we should
talk about. I agree that we should talk
about this. I agree that this topic is
worth discussing." Instantly, it's going
to pull down their guard. They're going
to go, "Oh, great. Okay, we can have
some communication. We can communicate.
He this person does understand there is
going to be acknowledgement there." And
so, you keep the argument down. You you
go back to a conversation because they
don't feel like they have to push and
press and prove to you. So, these are
phrases that really do mean a lot. With
the disclaimer here, I want to make sure
I add this. You have to make sure that
when you use these phrases that I'm
teaching you, you do them with true
intent.
Don't use these phrases to manipulate
somebody. So, don't say you agree that
this conversation is worth having when
you don't. Don't say that you agree that
this is this topic is worth is worth
discussing when you don't. That's that's
manipulative. When you try to control
their emotions in a way that is not true
and not genuine, that is a bad place to
go. And I don't want you to use these
phrases for that. These phrases are when
your intent and heart is true in it. So
don't if you don't find that what they
say was helpful. If you don't find that
you've learned something, then don't say
that. But if you have, I'm going to ask
that you be more objective in the
conversation rather than trying to pin
and poke in every which way to make them
wrong and and try to control their
behavior. That's manipulative and I
don't want that to happen. So with
number one, the focus here is don't
focus originally on the content. Focus
on the structure of the conversation.
That is, can you agree that this
communication needs to happen? And if
you can, use that phrase because it's
going to make them less defensive. On
the second response where you tell them
what you've learned, I want you to put
yourself in position of student and
teacher. In that moment, you are trying
to what we've talked about in other
episodes. You're having something to
learn, not something to prove. So, when
you can use the phrase, I've learned.
Thank you for telling me. I I've learned
something new here. I've learned this
topic is important. I learned that you
really care about this. I learned this
is special to you. When you say, I've
learned it, it makes it a student
teacher mentality to where you're
saying, "This is something new for me. I
am getting this information. I am now
inputting it into my system and I've
learned something. We're growing. we're
progressing in this communication and it
makes them less defensive because it it
makes them feel like they've taught
something. They're going great I I have
shared a part of myself that you are
taking and acknowledging and accepting
and now we can have this communication
without me feeling like I have to get
defensive in any way. It's very much the
same thing for response number three and
that is you tell them that they've been
helpful.
The word help is very critical there
because everybody loves to be helpful.
They want to feel like they've been
helpful. People just it makes us feel
good if I feel like I've helped somebody
else. It makes me feel good if I can
help somebody uh understand more about
me or understand more about something
else that's important to me. So when you
are in that position where they have
shared something with you and you can
say that's helpful to know instantly it
relieves that pressure of them having to
feel like they're proving something to
you that they have to get defensive.
You're saying that's that's helpful for
me to know. And so you are telling them
you're being helpful to me. They're
going great awesome. Okay we can be in
this together. I help you you help me.
That way we can communicate. It's that
two levels of there is understanding and
acknowledgement. And when you have that
together, that's called connection. And
it's an awesome thing.
>> Lots of questions going through my mind
of what I want to ask you next. Um,
>> you have a very calming demeanor, by the
way. I mean, we just we just met, you
know, 10 minutes ago, 15 minutes ago,
and I I came on to the recording. I was
like super frazzled, was a couple
minutes late,
>> and just the first few words out of your
mouth, I was like, "Oh, he's a calm
presence. He has like a very soothing
voice and
>> felt my, you know, felt my frustration
and anxiety decrease a little bit just
with that." Is that intentional? Like,
have you intentionally
learned
how to present yourself and how to show
up in a certain way um in order to just
deflate a situation?
The answer is
that comes naturally from what I have
what's been modeled for me.
>> I I I have I will absolutely say that I
have been blessed in a way to see models
of diplomacy in my family and how they
handle and address conflict. I'd grow
up, I'd get so mad. I mean, I'm a
teenager. I'm getting mad at my mom.
She's trying to control me. She's trying
to do this. And I'd come to dad and dad
go, "So,
you know, like, but dad, I got this this
this. You don't understand." He'd go,
"So, you know, I mean, and it would be
like, oh, man, what?" Yeah, he's he's
he's right. And so, his whole thing was,
you know, hey, don't don't make that
your Alamo. In other words, don't is
that the hill you're going to die on?
Really? And he was just so good at like
deconstructing
a lot of the ways I would I would feel
that. And it became very natural to me
in my demeanor to slow down. And as an
attorney especially, I very much honed
that behavior because my sole job is to
send my clients into just intense
conflict. So I have to train them and
teach them and calm them down in in very
um significant ways.
And a part of that is what I've learned
now now that I've like working backwards
of why why is that
um that my lower voice or using a
calming voice, a slower register which
comes very natural to me actually makes
other people's
um their their sympathetic nervous
system like it matches their energy and
the frequency to calm them down. So they
often times it would be different if I
came on and I just started yelling or I
was really intense. you're going to also
feel that intensity. So, we tend to
mirror each other. And so, when I come
in, I'm a lot more calming and talking
about our day and how's your morning
gone, then your body's like, "Oh, I
like, okay, I can match this frequency."
And then it kind of just starts to ease
>> to ease in to ease down. That's for
sure.
>> Yeah.
>> Let's talk about the the person who is
angry, wants justice, believes they're
right, wants their way. Yeah,
>> you probably deal with some of these
people
>> every day.
>> Every every day. Uh what is your what
have you seen work? How do you get
people to shift their mindset and shift
their behaviors so that the other person
can actually hear what they're trying to
say?
>> So let's put it in a context. Let's say
um let's let's put it I assume for your
readers it's marriage, it's
relationship.
>> Mhm. Let's put it let's put it uh
contextually. They they come into the
kitchen. What's what's happening?
>> Yeah. Okay. They come into the kitchen
and let's say they're it's a let's say
it's a wife. She's been working hard all
day getting the house clean, making
dinner, and for the fifth night in a
row, her husband is not home on time for
dinner like he said he was going to be.
And it's not just the fact that he's not
home. Uh it's he doesn't respect me. He
doesn't love me. This isn't right.
>> Right. And so he comes in and he doesn't
see what the big deal is. And she's
upset and feels
disrespected and unloved. And what she
says to him is, "Why are you never home?
Why don't you want to be with me? You
need to change. Like, we have to start
spending more time together." So on and
so forth.
>> That's hard.
>> And let's let's make it even harder.
Let's say kids are around.
>> Yeah. Let's absolutely. They're sitting
at the dinner table.
>> Let's make it Yeah, let's make it more
Let's make it even harder. Kids are
sitting at the dinner table. They're
already finishing dinner and husband
comes in late.
>> So, mom has a choice at that moment. Do
I do I address this now or do I address
this later? Now, that I think the first
part of it is is personal preference. I
would recommend that it is not addressed
in front of the kids. That's just my
that's my personal belief. I grew up in
a household that if you wanted to have a
significant argue, you know,
conversation, even if it was an
argument, it needs to be done away from
child's ears because they don't they
don't understand the context.
>> Um, and I don't I don't believe that
kind of behavior should it turn ugly
should be modeled in in front of kids if
you if you can't have it in a healthy
way. But it sounds like under our
scenario, it's not going to be had in a
in a very healthy healthy way.
So dinner goes exactly as it should. You
can either choose to address, say, you
know, hi, dad's here. Let's finish
dinner. Let's have bed. Let them have a
good night's sleep. Let them have a good
night's rest.
>> Then you turn to address the
conversation in in the room. What you
don't want to do is start off with a
why, like pushing the why question. Yes,
that's the question you want to know.
But when you put it in terms of a why,
very much feels like a challenge. So it
pushes a threat to our our body of
challenging your autonomy. It challenges
your competence.
If I were to just say to you, Kimberly,
let's say you did something, I say,
why'd you do that? Our immediate
response is because I wanted to.
>> That's right.
>> You know,
>> who are you to question me?
>> Yeah. Yeah. uh because that's what I
wanted to do. What's what's into you?
>> So it it works the same way. You have
times where if you start with why it is
immediately going to put them defensive
because it is a challenge. It is a is a
trigger to people. So the first question
I my style is very much a a diplomatic
let's come to the root of the matter
>> because if you just start complaining
that they're late, they know that
they're late.
>> So you complaining that they're late
does nothing in terms of resolving the
real issue, right? It's just you
venting. If you need to vent, tell them
that you're going to vent. if you need
to put a frame around it. I just need to
vent to you for a second. I want to talk
about this later. You know, I want to
talk about it afterwards, but I I need
you to be a place to to just vent.
They probably aren't going to want to
hear that. Bigger issue is going to need
to be um you know,
where is this coming from in terms of
the repeated
behavior?
a very much more powerful way I think
way to address this is do I need to give
up on the idea of you coming home on
time
um because if you ask it that way
they will answer in the negative of like
no no you don't need to I can do this I
can do this at the same time you need to
be very mindful of
what's happening in their day as to why
they're late and that that means you're
asking questions more along the lines of
um
what happened today?
How was your day? Like finding out
because you really don't know,
>> right?
>> Most of the time if you just like
typical scenario, right, Kimberly, is
they come home late, kids are down.
Great. So, you're just going to be I
guess you're just never going to be
home. Is this what it is? Like you said
you were going to be home the other
week. You have no clue what happened in
his day.
Who Who knows? It could be something
where it's uh maybe it's something at
work, maybe it was traffic, maybe it was
who knows. So, you always have to have a
pause to understand what's what's really
happening in their world. If it is a
complete sign of disrespect that they
know that they're being late and they
just don't want to be around,
>> that's much more of a boundary that you
that you need to put up and be much more
assertive and aggressive with it. Um,
that means that sounds more along the
lines of I'm interested in a
relationship that shows up. If you're
not interested in that in being with us
at dinner, I need to know that. Now,
there are times where I think you need
to ask them in ways that want them to
talk to you rather than want them to
close up to you. Often we feel like the
answer is to attack when that just makes
some claim up more rather than trying to
be understanding of what what is it
about what is it about us that makes you
not want to be here.
Uh and that that starts to crack that a
whole lot more. H and it also I mean the
other part of that is
being able and willing to hear what they
might honestly say.
>> Yeah.
>> Because sometimes those answers back
might be well then no there is something
about us that makes me not want to be
here
>> and here it is. Right. And then that can
lead to a cycle
>> of
poor interaction, poor communication.
Yeah. You'll get in a circle. Yeah. How
many times you get in a in a It's
cyclical where you're getting in an
argument, you come to the same place,
but it just gets worse.
>> It just gets worse. And and Jefferson, I
can imagine that, you know, with have
you having a history, a family history,
a professional history, just the
experience in your life, the the the
what's the word I'm looking for? like
the importance that you have put on
communication just in general for you.
You probably tend to show up
>> communicating well in your in your
conversations and in arguments, but
there
>> are probably people that you get in
arguments with or disagree with and they
don't give the same
kindness back, right? Like they don't
think of not using not saying it in a
challenging way and saying why, right?
So, how do you handle? So, we can still
continue to use the example of the the
wife who's mad at the husband. So, let's
say the wife is doing all these things.
She's approaching it in the right way,
not asking why, but looking to see what
the core issue is, but he is using all
the wrong communication styles and
blaming her and X, Y, and Z, and she's
having to like keep her calm in the
middle of a very difficult conversation.
How would you recommend to continue on
in that conversation when the other
person is difficult to talk to?
>> Oh, yeah. Well, that's that's just about
any argument. They're going to be
difficult to talk to, especially when
you're trying to calm things down in a
way.
>> So, what has been very beneficial for me
>> is that I frame my arguments at the
outset.
M
>> um so let's say I'm the wife in this
situation
and I know deep down he's a good dad or
that he really loves us. That's not the
issue. You know, there's not a fear of
like are you going around? Do you not
love me? That's that's not the issue.
It's just he's not he's not coming home
when he says he's going to come home. M
>> um to me you can frame a conversation by
one acknowledging what you know and a
quality you want them to have. So if you
and I can really in a maybe let's say
you and I are in an argument and
I can start at the outset of saying look
I know that
being on time is important to you. I
know that attention to detail is
important to you. I know that respect is
important to you. Whatever quality I
want you to have at that time, want you
to show up in, I say it. I speak that
over the conversation. So if I am the
wife, I said, "Look, I know that you
love us and you love our children."
And so you get what I mean at the
outset, boom, you you set the tenor of
they are now not going to be feeling
threatened of I have to show you how
much I love you, but I do this, but I do
that, but I I mowed the yard, but I I
did this. I paid the bills. I'm working
like I I know I know that you work hard
for us and our family. Boom. I've
already calmed it down. That's that's
you you've hit a fear that they could
have. Then you frame it. You put an end
to the conversation. Not not an end, but
you put a backs stop to it. I want to
have a conversation with you, a real
conversation with you about you coming
home late. And at the end of it, I want
to know why you're not coming home late
and ways that we can think together of
making sure you're home on time. I want
to be a help to that. Boom. You've now
put a backs stop on it. Say, "Hey, we're
going to have this conversation. Maybe
it gets ugly. Maybe it gets tense, but
I've already claimed at the end of it,
this is how I want this to go. Can you
agree to that?" And when you get their
buy in into the conversation on the end,
that's always better. So, a lot of
times, um, you don't have to agree how
to get there. You just have to be
aligned on the goal. So, if you can get
them to buy in on, are you willing to
engage in a conversation with me about
ways we can get you here on time?
They if they're down for that, okay,
then let's then let's talk about it.
What's what's happening? Uh, you're
going to find way more success than that
in this just throwing darts game.
>> Yeah. Because that's typically we just
like to send zingers, things that can
hurt. I'm here with the kids. You're
not. I have this. You're not. And all
you're doing is making you're hurting
them. You're def making them defensive.
And you're not at all addressing the
true issue.
>> A key takeaway I took from what you just
said is entering into the conversation
with
a goal.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And how often do people
not
every time. I mean, how many times have
we been in an argument and you think to
yourself
>> exactly?
>> Uh, how did this start? Where where was
going where was I going with this? You
go round,
>> where am I wanting to end? Or even like
what's the point
>> that too you go how one you say how did
we even how did we start? And then how
do we get out of this argument? Like
we've just we've lost our way. How did
this even begin? and you started talking
about ironing clothes and next thing you
know you're talking about, you know,
something that happened in 2007 on a a
bad date that you had. Like you just
>> you never know.
>> Goals. Goals. Knowing what you wanted
the end goal to be before you even start
often cuts down a lot on the fluff.
So,
you and your wife, do you just have
super effective communication, clear-cut
arguments that have a goal in mind,
like, or does she ever get frustrated
that she's up against someone who's like
a pro at communication? Or do you ever
get frustrated?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Maybe she's better at it than you. Who
knows?
>> Well, she's an attorney, too, actually.
>> Oh my.
>> Yeah. But we've known we've known each
other since we were teenagers. So, um,
knew each other long before we were
attorneys.
>> Yeah.
>> And all it means in terms of an attorney
is that she just knows
if I ever if well either one of us ever
go into cross-examination mode.
>> Explain what that means for the
listeners.
>> Uh, that means I'm I am asking questions
to prove a point.
>> Like I'm using my questions to prove my
point for me.
And so if I wanted, let's think of a
scenario. If I wanted to prove that, you
know, you left the garage door open. I
don't know. I'm just making something
up. And she's saying, "No, I didn't." My
cross-examination mode is um you know,
you had you had carpool that day. Yeah.
You you you left after I did. Yeah. I
didn't get home before you, did I? No.
You're the one who left the garage door.
like you like I'm I'm poking I'm using
my cross-examin my questioning to prove
my my point. So,
>> but isn't that effective in the
courtroom?
>> Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's what I'm
saying. It's it's not beneficial for
interpersonal relationship. It it's it's
>> Yeah. Yeah. I just mean that to say that
we're both very aware of when we go into
that mode. And as soon as we do, we're
very quick to say, "Do not cross-examine
me." Oh, yeah. Sorry. Like, it's it's a
it's just a habit. You can't you can't
really help it, but we're very aware of
of when that's happening.
>> When I'm in a conversation that I feel
like I'm
um it's getting away from me, let's say
that. That could be a sales negotiation.
It could be a conversation with a
friend, you name it. Um, I feel like in
my case, most of the time it's speeding
up faster than I want it to. You talk
about this in rule one. Number six is
control the pace. And as I listen to
you, I mean, you're very cognizant even
of your pace and the way that you
communicate even on the show today and
even in your content. You do you're
actually a little faster when you do the
content from your car than you are right
now on the show. you're even a pace
slower today than you are in your car.
So, I watch that like tonality and
pacing. Yeah. Let's talk about that in a
conversation cuz with my when emotions
run high often times for me, I feel like
the conversation is speeding up where my
my uh intellect is now not quite as
sharp as my emotions are running if that
makes any sense. So, what are strategies
to control the pace and what does that
even mean?
>> Yeah, I love that you picked up on that.
the anytime you are getting that fight
or flight and I know all of your
listeners highly educated they know
fight or flight whenever you're getting
emotionally flooded like that it is
that's why you're having trouble finding
your thoughts and connecting things and
that's why the quicker you get maybe
you've felt it where you you're either
nervous same thing when you're really
mad you might stammer and you might go
like no no no that that's not and you're
having trouble getting words out it's
because you're just flooded your
emotions are there your logical and
analytical side is not. And so what I
teach every one of my clients before
they go cross-examination and I'm just
offering them up to the wolves is a
constant reminder of you control the
pace, not them. That means no matter how
fast somebody is peppering you with
questions, the conversation cannot
happen any faster than you respond. So,
whenever they ask you a question and you
give a rapid fire answer back or worse,
you start to step over their question
because you already see where it's
going, bad things happen. You say things
you don't mean. You say things that are
not fully thought out. That's why even
in romantic relationships, all of a
sudden, you blurt something out and you
go, "Oh, I that's oh man, that's not
what I mean." And you you already knew
as soon as it came out of your mouth,
you put your foot in your mouth and you
messed up. It's because you weren't
controlling the pace. That means you
need to slow down your words and that
you need to leave space between what
they said and how you're going and when
you're going to respond. There's a
difference if you were to ask me
if if you said, "Hey, Jefferson, how was
your day?" And I said, "Good. It was
real good." I mean, it was it was it was
really good. Thanks. Versus, "Hey,
Jefferson, how was your day?" And I
said,
"It was good. It was a good day." Like
you can just hear the difference in
which one listened to the question,
which one thought about the answer,
which one makes the other person feel
acknowledged or heard. Same thing with
that's why rule number one is say with
control. If you go down and let's say
you're you're at work and all of a
sudden you go, "What's wrong? What
happened? What what's going on?" and you
all you're sensing and telling the other
person is you're grasping for control
versus you come in take a breath and
then you're saying all right what
happened give it to me like people are
looking like we said for those emotional
anchors so what I teach is let your
breath be the first word that you say
that's how you set the pace of a
conversation so where your first word
would be put a breath in its place and
what's that going to do is keep your
analytical side engaged and to where you
do not allow yourself emotionally to get
emotionally flooded and the bene second
benefit is neither does the other person
because now you are also injecting the
time and forcing them to slow down. The
never win an argument mindset is
something I believe so strongly in
because I have seen the opposite turn
out to be false every single time where
you always set out to win and there are
are books that are titled win every
argument. There are blogs how to win
every argument and I would read those
and just shake my head because I just
see that as such just snake oil salesman
just this how could you possibly try and
teach this to people because that's just
not real life. It's not real life. Um
even as an attorney
people say look you should don't you win
every argument. No absolutely not. that
it's it's it's nothing's in a vacuum. As
an attorney,
I don't really win arguments. I I have
facts. I can't I can't choose my own
facts that when a client comes in, they
have to give me what what the problem is
and I have to run with that. I got to
play the cards that are dealt. Same
thing with the law. I can't change the
law. I can't choose which law applies.
It's not like you get a a choice A, B,
C, D, all the above. Like there's you
are confined to a set of parameters and
you have to do what you can do best
which is advocate for your client based
on the parameters that are set. And you
have a judge, you have a court reporter,
you have a baiff, you have a opposing
council, and you have 12 jurors or maybe
six if you're in the county court. And
it's up to them, the decision makers, to
apply what you give to the law under the
rules of evidence to come to a decision.
Period. You see how many layers there
are. It's not just what I say. Now,
>> I will say there's a huge power in the
influence I have over a jury. And it has
little to do with what I say, but it has
almost everything to do with how I make
them feel, how I ex how I carry myself,
how I my client carries him or herself.
It is all this micro details. It's not
this big. The person who comes in and is
grandiose just slinging thinking they're
everything. They're the one that's going
to lose almost every every time. The
person who thinks that they have it all
prepared. The person who comes in with
the shiny, you know, the fancy suit,
Rolex, shiniest shoes you've ever seen
that came in in their Mercedes. I'll
show you that's an attorney who will
lose. Uh because it's not relatable to a
jury. Never is. In fact, I'll even tell
you this. Some of the best trial
attorneys that I've seen, of course,
they make lots of money. Um but they
also don't go to court in that vehicle.
They have other vehicles that are old
and used that they keep they've had
their whole life. This is like the
vehicle they had
>> when they first started out
>> because they don't want the jury to see
it. And so they won't wear their
fanciest stuff. They won't drive the f
wear all their fancy stuff. They will be
as normal as they can possibly be
because that is relatable. Um so it's
it's funny how even when you pull into
that parking lot in front of the
courtroom, you are you are on display at
all times. And so the jurors will watch
every move that you make.
>> So why do you say never win in an
argument? Because that that's kind of
like all of us fantasize, you know, five
minutes after we've had the argument,
we're like thinking through what we
should have said
>> or what we could have said, which by the
way goes to the title of the book. But
>> yeah.
>> Yeah. Just back that up a little bit.
>> The question is, do you always want to
win an argument? When you set out to win
an argument, you often will lose the
relationship. Like if you only see it as
something to win, that means you're
going to lose a lot more. Let's ask the
question of what have you won. Okay, I
said the thing that hurts you. I said
the one thing that took it too far. Now
you're leaving the room. Now you want to
hang up the phone. Now you're the one
who's upset and I'm the one left
standing there alone. What have you
Congrats? What what what have you got?
And you've you've most likely
won to be the first to apologize.
Really? That's what you want in in
relationships, especially like at
married.
>> You've wanted to be the first to
apologize. The one who's the last the
one who says the thing the last
>> who has to say who has to be the last
one to get the word.
>> You're first up to apologize. Congrats.
Swing away. Like it is just this
mentality that we have to have of being
competitive in conversation and heated
arguments where that's just that's you
will lose that. You're going to lose
their respect. You're going to lose
their trust and over time you're going
to lose their relationship. I mean who
who wants to be around the person who
always has to be right. I mean who that
that is somebody who is lonely. And that
is somebody who will eventually isolate
themselves out because nobody's going to
want to be around that person. What I
teach and the whole thesis of this book
is instead of seeing arguments as
something to win, you see them as
something to unravel. Meaning we we
you're going to take the loose ends.
Like if I have there's a direct string
between me and y'all and I'm saying,
"No, you have to go my way." And you're
saying, "No, you have to go my way."
Well, all that knot does is it gets
tighter and tighter. And the harder we
pull and the longer we pull, the harder
it becomes to undo, the harder it
becomes to unravel. And sometimes it
takes a whole day to unravel it. Maybe
it takes a week before emotions die
down. You're willing to look at it. Or
sometimes, you know what, it's it's over
a year. Some people haven't spoken to
their adult child or their parent. and
whatever it is. And it happens to the
closest of people,
>> they haven't spoken in years because of
how tight they made that knot. And so
that's that the quicker you are to
apologize, the quicker you are to to
start seeing where they're coming from,
that that knot never tightens.
>> Okay, Jefferson, I have to play devil's
advocate for a second. So there are
times that you want to persuade someone.
You know, maybe there's a lot at stake.
Maybe there's something really important
that needs to happen. Um, my husband and
I are dealing with this right now in an
extended family situation. But in a
situation where you do want to persuade
somebody, it's not about winning per se,
but you but you need to move them maybe
for their own best interest. First of
all, is that valid? Second of all, how
is that different from like winning an
argument? And do you help people learn
how to be more persuasive but in a way
that ultimately is good for a
relationship?
>> Great question. Winning has to do with
I'm the last one standing and you know I
have won. That's very different from we
need to take action and I need your
cooperation or I need you to understand
and I need to connect with you on the
action that's going to be taken. Winning
says I have no respect really for your
feelings. I have no respect for your
point of view. I'm willing to say
whatever it takes for you to go away.
That, as you know, that has the the
fight or flight. It's the it's this
mindset of I am going to be the king of
the the rock, whatever it is, the king
of the mountain, the king of the hill,
the person that's left here. I'm the one
that is right. You're the one that is
wrong. Got it? That's that's winning.
um the mindset of we have a choice to
make and either you're going to be with
me on this choice or you're not. Either
way, it's going to be fine with me. I'm
still going to respect you. I'm still
going to understand you. I'm still going
to hear your opinion. Like my dad would
put it to me this way growing up. If I
disagree with something, let's say I'm
17, a lot of things I think I know the
way of the world. And I would disagree
with what he'd say. anytime I would
complain, he'd say, "Well, you don't
have to like it. You just got to
understand it." I mean, it it would be
his like way of telling me, you know,
"Hey, you feel free to disagree. This is
what we're going to do." Um, and and so
it it was such a good lesson. Now, I
didn't appreciate it. I can promise you
that. But it I now I have that the the
hindsight of saying he he gave me the
freedom to disagree and it took all the
fight out of it. It was I'm giving you a
chance to connect with me. I'm giving
you a chance to understand where we're
going. And that's that's the key with
connection is you can I can still
disagree with you and still connect with
you. I can still I can still be unhappy.
I can still be mad at you and still
connect with you. So if you need to come
to a mutual decision on something that's
very different that is more of a
coordinated dance
>> um where there is going to be an exit
from this a win of an argument says I am
pushing you out of it very different
>> you say we have one of the best great
secret weapons of pausing
>> yes
>> so talk to me about in that moment if
you start to feel the heat you start to
boil your blood's boiling cuz someone's
being disrespectful to they're
dismissing you. Take me through the
exact steps of how do you pause,
>> how do you collect your mindset and then
come up with a good response.
>> Yeah. So, what I talk about is
difference between short pauses and long
pauses. And when somebody says something
disrespectful, what you want is a long
pause. That's somewhere between about 5
to 8 seconds. It's just a few seconds of
allowing the other person to hear what
they said. Because let's say you said
something negative to me. Visually one,
it's going to give me the feeling of
confidence when I see that word come and
just fall to the ground and
understanding I don't have to pick that
up.
>> And it's kind of in that silence you're
looking at it going, "Is that is that
what you wanted to say? Does that feel
good?
>> That that right there are you looking at
what I'm looking at?" And that right
there automatically makes them feel more
powerless and you feel more in control.
And that pause, you are being their
echo. You're being their mirror. So
often if somebody were to say something
ugly and I say nothing at all, often
what they do is they they say it and
hear it back in their mind. And often
people might apologize and go, I'm
sorry, I shouldn't have said that or
they rephrase it. Or you can ask the
person a, "Was that supposed to?" These
are questions of what I call intent. So
was that supposed to hurt me? See how a
question doesn't respond in the way of
sending that zinger back at them. It's a
way of answering without answering. Did
you mean for that to hurt me? Was that
supposed to embarrass me? And you see
how the power is not sending the zinger
to say, "I'm going to make you hurt even
worse." The power is when they throw a
punch, you go, "That didn't hurt." So
that's that's the control that you have
in that moment.
>> And I assume tone matters cuz even just
the way you said it, it was so calm. I
assume that was supposed to hurt me. Why
did you say that? Versus like, I assume
that was supposed to hurt me. Why did
you say that?
>> Exactly. So take me through how it can
be perceived as you're losing control
versus actually you have control of this
the conversation.
>> Yeah. I mean you can use just what we
did as an example. So if I were to say
you can't talk to me like that. Are you
kidding me? Versus
you cannot talk to me like that. Now
which one sounds more in control?
>> Oh definitely the second.
>> Definitely the second one. And nothing
changes except that you're speaking a
lot slower which shows I'm in control of
my words. And it also shows I'm in
control of my actions because when that
fight or flight kicks in, which you know
all about, you get that emotion, your
heart starts to beat, you get nervous,
you start to shake, your voice might
tremble a little bit, you get tears in
your eyes, it's just the emotional
flooding. You're telling your body in
that moment when you're not taking a big
pause and a big breath. You're telling
your body, I have a lot to fear right
now.
>> I have a lot to be afraid of, so I have
to be extreme. I have to say that
extreme thing. I have to go all out.
Versus when you slow down and you speak
slowly and even in a lower tone, you're
not only conveying control, you're also
telling your body
this there's nothing to fear here.
>> There's no nothing to threaten me. I'm
safe. And that right there is an
incredibly powerful move uh that you can
flip that script on them to show that
there's nothing here that's that's
threatening me in some way. So that's
what a lot of the pausing does is it
gives a lot of space for them to realize
that what they wanted is not what
they're going to how I see it is when
you say that ugly thing you put it out
on a ledge like you exposed it and
you're hoping you're praying that
somebody will take it. Have you ever
thrown an insult and then they didn't
give it back
>> probably.
>> Yeah. And then you go kind of feel like
a jerk later. You realize oh that didn't
hit. and then you feel kind of stupid
because what you sent out it didn't get
the response. You didn't get the control
and now you feel kind of silly about it.
So that's that's how you do that. So if
I had to break that down, it' be one,
you want to add about a five to seven
7se second pause, long pause. Two, you
want to do it long enough to make them
hear their words back. Often you can
just repeat what they said back to them.
So if you said something ugly like you
ever seen, you're an idiot and I waited
five seconds that said I'm an idiot.
Perfect. Three is you're you're allowing
them to show you can ask questions of
intent. Did you mean for that to
embarrass me? Did you say that to hurt
me or offend me? And often times that's
all you really need to do to realize
it's not going to be that fun for them
the second time around.
>> Oh my god, that's so good. And then in
talking about the pause in the power of
it, you also talk about in your book the
power of people forcing you to not
pause. And it's their way almost of
asking your question like rushing you to
answer as a way of them controlling you.
>> Yeah. So in legal depositions, attorneys
do it all the time. We want to get you
responding very quickly. And when you
feel pressured, you often do. A lot of
the clients that I have, I have to train
them on let them get all their question
out, give it a pause, then you say
something because otherwise you want to,
hey, did you go the other day? Yes, I
did. They they they like to cut in
because they just want it over. Same
thing in any argument that you have. You
also want that over because you want the
threat to go away. But where you find
the the moment of control and power for
them is when you can add distance
between what they said and your response
in that distance where you're able to
show them that there's nothing here
that's really going to defeat me in some
way. And so what I like to focus on is
when you are trying to rush your words,
what you're saying them is you're
afraid. Because when you get afraid, you
like to rush your words. And when you
get to slow down, you're in a much
better position almost every single
time. Confident people know they don't
have to say anything.
>> Insecure people always have something to
say, always have something to add.
Insecurities are loud. Confidence is
very quiet. There's a very big
difference in that. people in your
community would want to grasp that idea
of I don't have to say anything that I
don't want to say. Should I not want to
answer that text for 10 minutes? Maybe I
don't want to respond to that text for
the whole day. Then don't. It's there's
no pressure obligation that you have to
send it immediately. You don't have to
send that full paragraph. You wait. Wait
a day. It's going to be a whole lot
better. and you're the one that's going
to feel more in controlled and send the
message that you're in more control of
yourself.
>> How does somebody acquire
the skills to like slow down and not
feel as if
it'll work?
>> Yeah.
>> You know what I mean?
>> Let me tell you something that will help
or help that has helped me and let me
tell you said I work on this all the
time.
>> All right. I'm I am no different than
anybody else and I'm probably worse. All
right. So, it's if I can, let's say it's
you, anybody
listening, it's think of you and your
partner and you're in a disagreement.
All right? Typically, there's something
that is said that I'm going to grab on
to because I disagree with it strongly
and it might be something small like you
always, you never, and I'm like, I I I
never, are you kidding? Don't you
remember? And I just take off. All
right. Now, if I have the mental
discipline to just take it as a cloud
passing of like, okay, noted. That's one
thing I don't like, but I'm going to
keep listening. Nope, I don't like that
either. I'm going to keep listening.
rather than storing them up as
ammunition and sidelining it. If I can
just pause and put away my disagreement
for a second, my frustration for a
second and take that moment to
acknowledge first, reach understanding
first to say, "Yeah, that that I can see
why you're frustrated. That sounds
really frustrating. That is not at all
what I meant to do." and watch them calm
down.
Then then I can say and then they'll be
open to me saying, "Can I share
something with you that that I'm
struggling with?" All right. You you
said that I never
and usually by the time I even get to
that you you said that I never they're
what I've had many times is they'll say,
"Yeah, I I know it's not never. I was
just frustrated with if you can just
pause." I'm telling you said if you just
are able to take the frustration and set
it aside even for a little bit and just
acknowledge first it opens up everything
to be able to then you can one sift out
is that thing that I was disagreeing
with really that important or is that
just me trying to protect myself and be
defensive.
>> Mhm.
>> It's it's really the the modes of
protection. I'm going to be dismissive.
I'm going to say that thing that
insulting thing. I'm gonna make it hurt
just to protect my own self because I
don't like being called out. I don't
like being told that I'm wrong. I don't
like being told I could have handled
that differently.
>> Um, as soon as you are able to just set
it aside and understand first, reach
validation first. Yeah, that sounds
really frustrating. Of course, you would
be upset by that. Yeah, if if that's
what you you took away from that. Yeah,
I could definitely see why you're
frustrated. Boom. It slows everything
down. Yeah.
>> And then you can address, hey, you said
something that
um hurt me and I want to talk about it.
You said this. Now you're able what's
you're going to find is repair there
rather than trying to take off on
something that within 5 minutes you're a
million miles away and you don't even
know how you got there anymore. That I'm
telling you that's
>> that's been the key for me. I I I can't
imagine there being a better way to to
slow conversations down and I know we're
really harping on not we're really
focusing on deep relationship work
>> right now
>> which I think I like deep yeah I think
deep relationship work is what matters
like it was interesting when we were
talking you were like well I'm talking
about the people that we really care
about and like see that was the key like
that's what we're talking about the
people that we care about cuz like I
mean I'm telling you Jeff Jeff I can
like I can be like bro who's that like I
ain't got nothing to say to
I'll pass you up quick.
>> Exactly.
>> But the people that I care about does
that's I'm I'm constantly working on how
I can communicate better. And there's
nothing better than pausing.
>> And when you And it's funny cuz when you
first start pausing, it's really
uncomfortable for everyone. For everyone
that's uncomfortable, especially when
we're just conditioned to like go have
an answer right away that isn't even
>> thought through. Well, you know what I
mean?
>> Um like a deep relationships is what we
all crave. And that's why I wanted to
talk to you about that because
we don't really know how to navigate
them well because we're working with
what we with the information that we
have which is typically from our parents
how we were raised and some people may
have had good communication skills but
what's funny is when you get with
somebody in relationship kids wife
friends you come from two completely
different worlds and when you come
together there's going to be some some
tustling there's going to be some um
disagreements only because again our
communication isn't there like we don't
know how to communicate to each other in
the air quotes right way. You know what
I'm saying?
>> Yeah, I do. I do.
>> So, it's like constantly I love what you
said um another thing you said about
like the clouds passing by. I'm kind of
like a visual guy and I'm like think
about it like oh yeah like oh she said
that like all right well all right well
I'm I'm it's like the clouds passing by
also see like the layers coming back
from like an onion and like I see myself
just pausing. It's like those are the
three things that I see. And I think if
I can do that for myself personally,
realizing I have to it's my job to water
the the roots. Don't pay attention to
like the the leaves and just focus on
like what my job is as a for this person
that I love. I mean, that's like the
bigger person, right? Like that's what
being the bigger person is,
>> right?
>> It is. It's be it's being the the
safety. It's that's what it is. Um M
like we mentioned,
we want we all deeply want somebody to
be with us in our messy because we have
a deeply rooted fear
that
I am too much or I am not enough and
this person's going to leave me.
that if I tell the truth
that they're not going to love me
anymore. And in many ways that turns
into lies. Protect me.
>> And
that is a very dangerous road. Uh that
is a that is a road of
corrosiveness that will hurt uh
everybody you love. So what what can you
do? I think what you just outlined is a
great way to to put this in a frame, so
to speak. One, whenever you get to that
situation of whoever you are with that
you have a a deep feelings for
one, what are the roots? That's asking
the question, what's coming up for you?
Asking yourself the question, what are
they feeling right now? What am I
feeling right now? when I can voice it.
That would be number two, voicing how
you're feeling. If I slow down and I
say, I can tell that I'm I'm getting
frustrated. I can tell that I'm getting
defensive. I can tell that
I I need some time. That is such a
higher level IQ move than me reacting to
that. There's such a there's a
difference between me saying I can tell
I'm getting defensive
versus me acting defensive and saying
are you are you kidding me? Oh yeah.
Okay. Me what about you? What about that
time that you and it's done.
>> You're never going to reach them now.
Now congratulations. You've now won
yourself three more arguments. You
you've now added on three more hours of
hard feelings between the two of you.
Like that's that's how quick it is to to
go off the the tangent. So, if you were
to number two, just vocalize it of how
you're feeling and asking how they're
feeling.
That's always going to help get to the
the roots. And number three, I'm going
to choose to no matter the situation,
you find yourself to be the the anchor
of the conversation, to show that you
can slow it down, that you're not going
anywhere, you're not trying to push the
conversation, you're not even trying to
push them. you're just here to listen,
absorb, validate,
and that's how you grow deeper. That uh
because now I now the other person feels
like you can be trusted. Now they feel
like your your bond is closer with them.
Like think of it with with our kids.
Yeah. How old are your kids?
>> Eight, six, and three.
>> Okay, there you go. So we're we're very
similar. All right.
When I is Isn't it true that when you
look at your one of your kids so often
you see yourself
>> Oh yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. So my son, he's seven.
He will say things and react in ways and
I go, "Oh my gosh, that is so me.
>> Oh my goodness, that is me." And it is
such a teaching tool for me because
we're all just big kids. I mean, I look
in the mirror and I go, "I can't believe
I look this old." Like I my dad would
always tell me I I he always say I look
in the mirror and and ask who's this old
man
>> you know because on the inside we're
we're just the same. We we feel on in
mentally like we're in our 20s like
we're not old enough to be adults yet.
And now all of a sudden we have kids and
responsibilities but emotionally we a
lot of us are still the same way. We
were never we were never validated at
the age of eight. We were never
validated at the age of 18. Why in the
world would we feel validated at the age
of 48?
>> It's all the same. It's all the same.
And so when I can see my child and take
that as a reflection of God, I feel the
same way when he's reacting like this.
Yeah. I I feel that frustration too. My
daughter, you know, I we always know
when she's upset cuz she will just out
of nowhere will hear a like a big she's
just, you know, she can't get her hair
the way that she wants. Yeah, she's
frustrated that she can't get her shoe
on the right way. Like she and so am I.
My wife will go,
>> "Yeah, that's me." Like it's it's just
so funny to they're just little uses
around
>> and to say this is my chance to
>> to see that that I'm still I'm still
there. So if my son needs that or my
daughter needs that kind of validation,
why would my spouse not? We're we're
we're we're all parents for the first
time. I mean, it's it's all it's all the
same. And so I I really love
I really I truly do love seeing
how much healing I can have in my own
life by observing the lived experiences
of my children when it comes to to
communication. how I can validate their
emotions. Yeah. I I didn't grow up.
Maybe you feel the same way.
>> Wasn't really okay to cry. Um really
wasn't. And my son, I let him just be a
waterworks. I mean, I I love I love all
the tears that he has. He feels his
emotions really big.
>> And I think for a lot of men, that was
taught early. That was not okay.
>> And there's a consequence to that, too.
So, it's it's it's good to see. I think
it's healthy. Would you agree that an an
inability to listen is probably the
biggest mistake people make when trying
to communicate effectively?
>> Yeah, I mean listening is part of
communication. People think that
communicating is often what we send out.
It's not. It's it's really what more
about what we accept.
In my view, you think about it like if
you're going to write a letter, like you
you get a letter in the mail, but you
can't read that letter and write a
response at the same time.
Well, that's what we do all the time.
>> Like every every day, we're not really
reading what they're saying. We're
either anticipating what they're going
to say or we don't care what they're
going to say. We're just focused on
writing the letter.
And that inhibits our ability to fully
appreciate and fully understand the
other person.
The it and it truly is a habit of
listening. I I mean I got to practice it
all the time. Mine is a little bit
different because it's part of my
profession. So when I ask witnesses
things, I am listening because if I
don't, they could tell me something
that's very good for my case and I miss
it because I'm writing down a note. I'm
focused on what my next question is
going to be, just like you were talking
about. But the power to listen
not only shows that you're acknowledging
them, which makes them want to tell you
more, it is crucial to exchange ideas.
And building on on that idea then of
again of listening and and and being
thoughtful in a conversation,
>> what I found from podcasting, having
conversations with people, interviewing
people, having people um you know
interview me, one thing I notice a lot
of people are scared of is silence. Um
they you know when when you ask a
question or somebody gives an answer a
lot of the time people are scared to
take two three five seconds to process
what the other person said. Think
consciously about what they're going to
say before they say it. A lot of people
I feel are are very uh self-aware of how
long it takes to reply and they want to
look like they boom they're on it. They
have the perfect answer that they're you
know that they're super smart. They
they're super attentive. But in reality,
to me, when I see someone pause, maybe
look up, take a few seconds,
I almost value what they're going to say
to me even more than if they replied in
an instant.
>> Yeah, very good. Yeah, that's that's
exactly right. So, one of um the tips
that I push when I go speaking at
different places
is when you let your breath be your
first word. And that sounds kind of like
hippie- dippy-ish, but it I mean it's
really a thing. And I I it's what I tell
my clients. It's what I practice. As if
my breath is my first word, the first
thing that I say,
it makes a difference in how it it how
it is perceived that I receive that
information. So if you were to ask me
uh I see that in your in your screen,
you say, "Well, Jefferson, do you like
the Beatles?" Right? Okay. And if I just
immediately said, "Yeah,
>> I mean, it just it makes it seem like I
didn't really put any thought into it,
right? It was just this kneejerk
reaction versus if you said, Jefferson,
do you like the Beatles?" And I went,
>> "Yeah, I like the Beatles."
>> Yeah.
>> Like it it all all of a sudden you're
like, "Oh, okay." Yeah. He just he just
searched in his mind for something. He
really took the time. You see this a lot
in panels. you there's a panel of four
or five people. The person who gets the
question, takes a breath and takes their
time and then responds,
>> you have them waiting like they're just
>> you have a captive audience because
they're waiting for what you're going to
say and it's makes makes it much more
impactful.
>> No, absolutely. I I absolutely love
that. And I wonder then if we are
dealing with someone, you know, in that
situation where they're talking back at
us, we finish our thought and they're
almost into theirs before we could even
finish ours. You know, they're cutting
over us. They can't wait to talk and
you're thinking, "They're not listening
to me. They're just queuing up what
they're going to say next when I'm
talking." How do we deal with someone
like that and turn that conversation
into an effective one or an effective
argument? How do we combat when we can
tell that someone's not listening to us?
>> Well, I mean, se several things go
through my head. It's it's definitely
contextual. The the first thing that
goes into my head is why are we talking
to this person? But but let's say it's a
it's a good conversation and they are
certainly not interested in what you
have to say. Let's say it's somebody
who's pushing their point or wanting to
prove a point and they're wanting you to
um contribute in some way. A lot of the
time I the first thing I'll ask is, "Is
this something you need me to agree
with?" I'll ask that. I'll say, "Is this
something you need me to to agree on?"
And typically they'll say, "No, no, I
don't. I mean, I just needed to tell you
about you XY." Well, okay. Because
before I I'm not telling them this, but
beforehand they're pushing, you know,
they're pushing pushing. Well, don't you
think why don't you like every time you
try to explain yourself, they're cutting
you off to try and corner you to
eventually just concede to their point.
Typically, I get rid of that by the
first second question. I say, "Is this
some Hey, just let me is this something
that you're needing me to to for us? Is
this something we're needing to agree
on?" That's what I'll ask. Is this
something we need to agree on? M
>> when I ask that it totally changes the
frame of um them saying actually no
we're just having a discussion great
good me too
>> if somebody is pushing um interrupting
you all the time I I have a kind of a
what's the word some some arrows in my
quiver of how I I handle that and
usually I let them interrupt the first
time but the second Um,
I will tell them calmly say, "I I can't
hear you when you interrupt me."
>> So, I'll say, "Hey, look, uh, Lewis, I
can't, hey, man, I I can't hear you when
you interrupt me."
>> And most of the time, it's the same way
it works with my kids. Like, when my
daughter or my son have a very whiny
voice on something and they come in
whining, I'll say, "Uh-uh, I can't I
can't hear you. I can't hear you." When
you talk like that, v all of a sudden it
changes.
>> Yeah.
>> They go right back to how they were.
It's just it's just trying to guide
them. And if you want me to hear what
you're saying,
>> you're gonna have to to talk in a
certain way.
>> Yeah. I mean, that that sounds far more
effective than just actively tell, you
know, trying to shout louder than the
other person. And I think that's when a
a conversation starts to become more of
a fight. And ultimately, when it becomes
a fight, no one's winning that argument.
>> No, nobody's winning that. then it just
becomes just then it just becomes worse.
But it's it's uh to really let people
know that so much of their communication
and the conflict has to deal with us.
Like how how we I can control how my
conversations generally go.
>> If somebody is being ugly to me, rude,
I'm in complete control whether they
have my emotions or not. I'm gonna allow
them to to affect me. And and a lot of
that is your pace.
I mean, just like we talked about, I I
slow everything down. My voice is going
to get lower. I'm going to go slower.
I'm more interested in why are they
saying this rather than thinking of the
next thing to say that will um that's
good for all things in life, but it
certainly has helped me. I was going to
say as you were talking about that then
um I was I I was thinking that you know
since we jumped on this call you have
you know your your your pace has been
quite slow you've you know in a deeper
voice and what I feel as though it's
doing to me is it's almost drawing me
closer to the screen and I'm I'm sort of
leaning in and and you know I'm leaning
in further to what you've got to say and
it's you know it's making me pay more
attention to you when you're talking to
someone are you is are things like that
something that you're always conscious
of or does this is this just sort of
second nature to you now or do you know
when to play on certain things when to
use little tactics like that?
>> Well, I'm just trying to I know it's
late over in your time, so I'm just
trying to trying to make sure it's easy
for you to go to sleep.
>> Yeah, you you got I'm going to start
tapping on the microphone here in a
second for you. Um, it's it's it's
second nature at this point, but it's
also something very intentional.
>> Yeah.
>> The way I and it's just natural with
anybody. The way you talk with your
friends, way you talk with your family
all very different than how you're going
to talk to me.
>> I talk to people in my video different
than I'm going to talk to my family or
my best friends. It's it's all just
it's circumstantial to wherever you're
at. I mean, context is is is a big part
of that. But I can tell you when I'm
trying to teach, when I'm trying to tell
a story, I will absolutely slow it down
because it makes people more interested
in every word. I mean, then they become
like very much like, okay, what's what's
this going to happen? versus if I'm just
somebody who's talking really fast all
the time. I'm just really so grateful to
be here. Thank you so much, Louis. Like
then it's just you turn you tune it out.
It's it's too much.
>> It's sort of like
>> at least for the southerners like me.
>> It's sort of like when you listen uh to
an audio book on two times speed and
you're not taking anything in at all.
>> No. And I did that before trying to take
my the bar exam for law school and it
was not a great idea. I did fine on the
exam, but I I Yeah, I didn't absorb any
of it.
I had a buddy of mine who recommended
that and that was a terrible that was a
terrible recommendation.
>> I wonder then we're talking about all
these little techniques. Um
a lot of people might you know they
might be listening to you talk about
these techniques like certain things
you'll say slowing your voice down. They
might be thinking that's a little bit
sneaky. I wonder if anyone's ever used
that on me. What would you say to the
argument and I have heard people pose
this argument that books and content on
persuasion on negotiation
um I've heard some people you know
describe them as manipulative um and
really put a a negative spin on it
rather than than a positive spin. It's a
subject I've always been very interested
in. you know, years ago when I read um
Never Split the Difference by Chris
Voss.
>> It's something I've always been
interested in, but I have viewed people
take the opposite sort of stance on it.
What would you say to those people?
I would say I hear you and I see where
you're coming from because there are
certainly aspects of
I I'm going to call it kind of the
darker
the the darker alleys back alleys of
communication and that are the people
who really push you know sales
techniques or different ways to keep
people on the phone get people to say
yes. You're taking advantage of people
who might be what they call more
weak-minded. you know that somebody
who's just very susceptible to going
along with whatever you say that to me
can be manipulative and there's
certainly people that manipulate in
conversation. I like to think that I am
part of the light in communication. And
that means I I want to teach people to
speak with compassion and empathy and
grace for for the other person. And
when I say like, okay, if I'm going to
slow my words, make somebody feel more
invited, more attentive. I feel like
those are all things I want them to feel
because I I want them to know that I'm
paying attention. I think of like my
kids. if I need to calm my kids down or
if I need to tell them something
important,
that's exactly the kind of tone that I'm
I'm going to to take. Because in some
sense, if you're if you're the leader in
your life,
it's up to you to guide people and
shepherd people
into making them feel safe and together.
And that's that's what I try to push out
of these positive experiences and
interactions that you can actually
predict uh based solely upon how you you
communicate. Are there people who would
use it to the other's disadvantage?
Absolutely. Those people I can't help
because they have bad intent and bad
motive. Now, that I can't fix, but I I
can certainly help you
learn to acknowledge somebody, to make
them feel more valued, to value
yourself, to feel like you can stand up
for yourself, lay more boundaries, all
these things that I think are much more
on the the healthier side of the
communication. The most persuasive
people don't argue their point, they ask
great questions.
>> Absolutely. If I could write that down
and put it on my mirror every day, I
that's exactly what I would do. Can you
tell us more about what that means to
you and how people can people listening
to it right now, how how can they apply
it in their everyday from the kitchen to
the living room to their workplace
asking great questions? No, it's a it it
what's really interesting is, you know,
when researchers started sort of
identifying these folks that we we call
consistent supercommunicators because
we're all super communicators at one
time or another, but but some people can
essentially kind of connect with anyone.
The number one behavior that they found
was that these people tended to ask 10
to 20 times as many questions as the
average person. And and and what's
interesting though is and we all know
people like this, some of the questions
you don't even register as questions.
They'll say things like uh you know, oh
what' you think about that or you know
what did you say next? It's these little
essentially invitations to share with
them. But then some of the questions
that they are very comfortable asking
are what are known as deep questions.
And a deep question is something that
asks someone about their values or their
beliefs or their experiences.
And that can sound kind of intimidating
right when I'm like oh you should ask
people about their values or their
beliefs or their experiences. Except
that it's as simple as, you know, if you
meet someone who's a doctor, instead of
saying, you know, oh, what hospital do
you work at? You could ask, oh, what
made you decide to go to medical school?
>> Right? That second question that invites
the person to tell you something real,
right? That invites them to tell you
sort of what they believe in or what
their experiences were as a kid that
sort of led them to where they are.
>> Yes,
>> that's a really powerful question. And
and so I think that the most persuasive
people, they recognize, the best
communicators, super communicators
recognize asking these deep questions is
just as easy as asking shallow
questions. But when I ask a deep
question, I'm inviting you to have a
real conversation with me. And when you
know that I'm listening to you, you
start to listen to me. And then and then
we're persuading each other.
>> Yes. Absolutely. It's um what I hear is
this everyday small talk that people
feel most people feel anxious about. I I
don't want to ask a question. I don't to
be too much. You can have surface
questions and deep questions. And the
great communicators have a wonderful
skill at making the deep questions sound
just like the shallow ones.
>> That's where you're not having to, you
know, feel like what is your deepest
desire? Tell me about your childhood.
like these things that like who I don't
I don't know you. Um is that is that the
way you feel about it? Like if you're
going to conversation and instead of
this what else question mark versus what
else like you finding ways of sounding
them make them sound like a statement.
So I'm trying to give the listener right
now some tips on that.
>> That's definitely half of it right is
that half of it is I can ask you a deep
question that sounds like a shallow
question. So, and often times that's
just a matter of asking you, here's
here's the big tip is instead of asking
you about the facts of your life, ask
you a question that would prompt you to
talk about how you feel about your life.
So, instead of just asking, you know,
where do you live? Oh, I live in the
Heights. Oh, what do you like about the
Heights,
>> right? Or, you know, it you can do it
with almost anything. It's very, very
easy. Now, the thing is that that's a
great way to start a conversation. And
there's a guy named Nick Epley at the
University of Chicago who's basically
studied deep questions his whole career.
I think that once you ask an easy to ask
deep question, it's actually much easier
and much more welcome to ask a deep
question that seems like a deep
question, right? If I ask you, you know,
what do you like about the Heights? And
you say, well, the sense of community is
amazing up there. Oh, yeah. What? Like
what? Like tell me about it. Like what's
the community? Well, you know, my wife
passed away a year ago and my neighbors
have been there for me. Then suddenly
it's totally okay for me to say, "Oh,
I'm so sorry. Like, tell me about your
wife. What was she like,
>> right?" What research shows is that we
don't have a resistance to deep
questions. We have a resistance to deep
questions that move a little bit too
quickly. But you can actually move fast
if you ramp up the intimacy. And so if I
ask you a question, and this is the
other thing that super communicators do,
and I I think you talk about this in
your own work a lot,
>> that they look for opportunities
where people are trying to tell them
what they want to talk about, right? So
let's take someone passing away. This is
the most my my own
>> my father passed away about seven years
ago
>> and I went back to work. I was working
at the New York Times at that point. I
went back to work and I had this this
experience that I think everyone has
had, which is, you know, people say,
"Oh, where were you last week?" And you
say, "Oh, I was at my dad's funeral."
And they all say the same thing. They
all say, "Oh, my condolences. I'm so
sorry." And then they move on to
whatever you were talking about before,
right? Because like they don't know what
to say.
>> But anyone who's been through that
experience knows that if somebody were
to say like, "Oh, like I'm so sorry."
Like tell me what your dad was like.
What was Because that's all you've been
thinking about for the last two weeks,
right? is you've been thinking about
your dad and the funeral and the
eulogies and how much they touched you.
And so I think what super communicators
do is they look for people to offer them
invitations and then they accept those
invitations. Even if accepting that
invitation means I'm going to ask you
something that maybe is not something
that that I normally would ask, right?
Maybe maybe I sit down next to you in a
in a meeting and you tell me about your
fact that you went to your kid's
graduation that weekend and instead of
just saying, "Oh, congratulations.
That's awesome. Let's get down to the
agenda." I say, "Oh, congratulations.
That's awesome. What did it feel like to
watch your kid walk across that stage?"
Yeah. That's when suddenly we're
connecting with each other. I love that.
Not asking about facts, ask about how
they feel. That's something that's
immediately applicable that somebody
could apply right now. And I what I see
too is in my line as in work of as an
attorney in cross-examination when
you're asking somebody questions a lot
of the time you can tell
what they're wanting to talk about based
on how they end their first sentence or
they when they end their answer they
might end it their answer just a little
bit short because they are trying to
invite you to let them in just a little
bit more to talk just a a little bit
more. So, it's very telling how they end
their answer. They might end it on like
a cliffhanger or somebody might say, you
know, yeah, and so they might they might
end it with a Yeah. So, you know, that's
and they just they they've kind of hit a
dead end. They're not sure how to get
there. And so, they're inviting you to
kind of help me walk me through that
door.
>> I think that's huge. And I think that's
such a such a great insight that like
just by paying attention to the to the
cadence of how they speak or they're
telling us stuff because the truth of
the matter is
>> sometimes when we're communicating with
someone, we assume that they are
communicating by accident, right? Oh,
you mentioned you mentioned your kid's
graduation, but you don't want to talk
about your kids graduation. You
mentioned that you were at a funeral,
but you don't want to talk about the
funeral. That's not how communication
works.
>> We mention things that we want to talk
about. Right.
>> Exactly.
>> We we avoid things that we don't want to
talk about. So, if somebody has brought
something up with you, that shouldn't be
like, "Oh, no, I kind of touched the
third rail there." That should be, "Oh,
this this person like they want me to
ask about that."
>> That's so funny. Yeah. So, my uh my
grandfather would have this habit of
when we'd be like at a restaurant all
together, and he'd ask you, you know,
Jefferson, is that uh h how's that that
fish? And I'd say, "Well, it's it's
great." And it was an invitation for me
to say, "Would you like a bite?" Like
that was that was always his like go-to.
If he would say, "Yeah, how's that?
How's that chicken right there?" And
it's his way of saying like, "That looks
good." And I didn't invite me go, "Would
you like it?" He goes, "Yeah, I think I
would."
>> Sounds like a super communicator. I
think he knew what he wanted out of the
conversation.
>> That's the invitation right there is is
what you're hearing. I love that. The
takeaway is instead of trying to push
your point even in the small little
everyday conversations, you find ways to
ask more questions. Super communicators
ask much more uh than the average person
on questions that they can put into
somebody else's life. So the takeaway is
invest in the questions.
>> That's exactly right.
>> Um exactly it. I love that.
>> Let's talk about active listening. M
>> uh this is one that I find to be very
interesting because I see that when many
people engage in conversation,
they're simply waiting for that person
to stop talking so they can download. Oh
yeah. On on them and and and and and
listen, there's no listening. There's no
active listening taking place. So a how
can we place oursel in a position where
we can be actively listening? And then
two, how can we position our
conversation to help the person we're
having a conversation with actively
listen?
>> Let's define active listening first for
anybody who has heard the term but not
really sure what it means.
>> What I consider it to be is we when you
are an active participant in the
conversation with your non-verbal and
verbal cues. You might hear somebody
like you, you're nodding right now
already while I'm talking. That's active
listening. You might you might hear
somebody go, "Mhm, that's right. Yeah.
Mhm." Like that kind of stuff is
signaling, "I'm in it with you. I'm
here. I'm listening." Now, there are
some people who might go overboard and
do it way too much and that's annoying.
You know, where you're like, "Yeah,
that's right." Mhm. the entire time.
There's a balance with everything.
There's balance. But most of the time
when you're nodding and you're going,
"I'm with you. Got it." Any of that kind
of stuff is active listening. You're an
active p participant in the
conversation. Now, aside from the
non-verbals, how can you be a better
active listener? What I like to
recommend is if you can mirror the end
of their conversation, it's going to
help. And the reason why I'm going to
define what that is,
active listening, whenever you can give
the non-verbal cues, is great. But if I
can take the very end of your sentence
and simply repeat it back to you, you're
going to feel like I heard you. You're
going to feel a lot more acknowledged.
Thus, a lot more connected to me. So, if
you were telling me something,
um, let's just say say, uh, I had a
really hard day today. Just say that to
me.
>> Yeah. I had a really hard day today.
>> Hard day. You're going to What do you
want to do now? What do you want to do
now? I
>> had a hard day.
>> Exactly. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And
you're going to start talking about it.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Uh, or if I were to say, "Tell me
more. Tell me more." Anything I can do
to just get them to continue to
>> more
>> to talk. Yeah. So, anytime you can
repeat just the last little some key
word at the end of their sentence,
>> it's almost giving them the permission
to keep talking because you know how
sometimes you don't want to take up too
much of your talking time. Yes.
>> So, you kind of cut it off early.
>> Yes.
>> In hopes that they might ask a little
bit more.
>> Yeah. And sometimes they don't. You're
like, "Ah man, they didn't want to hear
about my day." Okay. But it if you can
just give a little bit of repeating back
what they they said, they're going to
feel a lot more acknowledged or say,
"Tell me more. What do you have?" Let's
put this back on. What's a let's let's
lay it down in some rules. You want to
be a better active listener. Number one,
ask one question. Ask one question. Real
easy. By that, I mean, once they've told
you something, don't immediately go to
solving it. Don't immediately go to
having your two cents, having to have a
response. Ask one question. It could be
as simple as what was your favorite
part? Or what what do you think about
it? What's what's your opinion? What do
you think the answer is? Any little bit
of that question, they're going to have
an answer for it. They're not going to
they're not going to claim up. They're
going to continue to talk. That makes
them feel heard and acknowledged. Big
check mark. Number two, if you need to
be a better active listener, aside from
the little non-verbal cues we talked
about, repeat the last little bit of
their question. That's mirroring. that's
going to make them feel like you you
heard them in some sense. And number
three, if you can, and this is the most
difficult, Paul, is empty out the idea
of you having to spit something out
right away. It's very, it takes a lot of
discipline, but to actually listen
without formulating a thought, and you
can do that by your breath and adding
some space before you start to respond
to it. Because most of the time when
you're talking, we're only thinking
about how we're going to respond to it.
>> Yes.
>> That's why people interrupt.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. I love it. But now once again,
we've landed on the pause.
>> Yeah. It's powerful.
>> Which the pause is powerful, but I've
seen this in television. You know, there
was um you know, in in uh in in in TV,
what often happens in a lot of the shows
that I do is often times people cry.
>> And I I'll never forget uh a producer
once told me, "Paul, don't step on their
cry."
>> I can see that.
>> So, you know, people would start crying
and I would feel terrible. I say, "Oh,
no."
>> Yeah.
>> You know, I tried to hug them and hold
them and immediately start talking and
the producer said, "No, don't don't step
on their their cry. allow that emotion
to sit with them to to sit with them.
Right? And I found even in a therapy
context that's very powerful.
>> Sometimes you need to have a
conversation with the moment, not with
the person.
>> Meaning that you need to acknowledge,
appreciate, connect with the moment.
It's just as powerful. I there are times
when I'm with my kids, I don't have to
say anything, but I know I'm connecting
in that moment with them just by sitting
with them. And I know that they're
learning or they're going through
something or they're crying or they're
upset.
And there's times when you're talking to
somebody and there's nothing you can
physically do. You you of course you
have a because you have a wonderful
heart, you want to hold their hands, you
talk with them, step on that that cry
when sometimes you it's connecting to
the moment and that doesn't require any
type of communication at all. And that's
beautiful thing about life. I can sit
here in the room with you and we could
have nobody here and no cameras and we
could still connect to the moment and
still feel like we went through
something.
>> Yes.
So communication is beautiful in the way
that it transcends verbal. I mean I can
silence is is the absence of sound is
not the absence of communication. You
can say a lot of things in silence. And
so for people who
have a hard time with that, it's it's
communicating with the the moment that
that would be a much more positive shift
into using pauses and acknowledging and
observing the silence. If you enjoyed
that clip and want to see the rest of
the conversation, you can click right
here. Or if you want to see the latest
episode of the Jefferson Fisher podcast,
click right here and I'll meet you